hey what's up guys my name is eterno and
welcome to the July update video so I
thought I'd do a vlog style thing again
I thought I'd mix up the lighting a
little bit so you guys are seeing a
pretty cool shadow right there so let me
know if you kind of like this set up I
don't know I just felt like doing
something different but I'm making this
video because well first of all it's
July so July monthly update is a thing
also I believe there wasn't even a June
one so I think May was anyway point is
let's not get off topic here there's
gonna be quite a short update video just
outlining what's happening with the
channel and and a lot of other things so
first of all I want to thank you all for
40,000 subscribers that's pretty crazy
number I'm just picturing that many
people in like a little stadium just
watching my videos and it's pretty cool
so thank you for that
it's a certainly a really nice number to
hit it's a good milestone and and it's
something has been around three years
exactly since I started the channel so
it's pretty nice and I'm still really
excited to bring you guys more and more
content which is obviously a good thing
so that aside I did want to say that I'm
actually going away for a holiday to
Germany so I usually go to Germany every
year around June July for about a month
month and a half two months sometimes so
this time I'm going very very soon so
I'll be gone for about four weeks which
means that well a few things but first
of all yeah I just it's literally just a
holiday it's pretty cold here in
Melbourne and I know that all of you
people who live in like the snow don't
think it's cold but it's still pretty
cold here I mean it was like 4 degrees
this morning and I'm just not down to
deal with that 4 degrees Celsius by the
way obviously um anyway that all that
aside that shadow is probably really
distracting and I'm sorry about that
there anyway so I'm going to Germany
because it's summer there and that
should be great there should be a lot of
fun but what I'm actually gonna do this
time is I'm not really gonna take all my
gear with me and make videos so last
time I made something and before that it
was like Network chat programming I did
oh yeah last time I started the flappy
bird series
last year during like while I was over
there over there this year I'm actually
not gonna do any of that I'm not going
to take any kind of video recording
equipment with me or video making
equipment so like my microphone or your
interface all that stuff I'm just gonna
have a holiday okay now the reason is
this year I'm actually working full-time
at AAA for those of you who don't know
Electronic Arts so I'm going to work
every day from like 10 till 6 so it is a
bit different than just being in
University and certainly I do want a bit
of a break but also I just you know I'm
not going for that long I'm gonna go for
4 weeks this time not like eight weeks
or whatever like the last time so um
it's not gonna be a big deal you guys
won't even notice me not posting videos
for a while because I'm pretty much
doing that now anyway but anyway this is
getting a bit bit carried away I do want
to say though that I will still be
working on Sparky though I'll still be
committing stuff I'll still be I don't
know how much internet access I will
have over there but I will still be
doing all of that stuff so don't worry
too much about that I will still be
working on Sparky and whatnot and it
should be a lot of fun I might if I have
the time and if my laptop microphone is
good enough I might make like a little
Sparky update video like I promised I
would but apart from that nothing really
major is gonna happen so it should be it
should be it should be pretty good time
for me and I'll certainly hope to get
quite a bit done in terms of Sparky so
that's always good maybe pop in maybe
even like actually commit the Android
build and whatnot and possibly get some
tools going so that should be good among
other things of course but that's pretty
much what's gonna happen with the
channel now one thing I did want to
point out that I haven't actually
pointed out in any kind of video is
whilst I haven't been posting game
programming videos which is basically
all I posted this channel apart from
like these kind of vlogs or update
videos is I do actually have because I
have been live streaming a lot right
several times a week usually except it
is last week because I'm busy packing
and whatnot but I have been live
streaming a lot and all of those streams
are actually being saved into
channel called China archive okay now
because of YouTube's new URL settings it
doesn't actually have a proper URL yet
but they'll be a link in the description
to that channel so I post every every
stream there just straight from twitch
just gets exported right into that
channel so go ahead and subscribe to
that channel if you want if you don't
want to miss live streams but yeah but
just so you know that's where they're
all going so whilst I haven't actually
been posing stuff through this channel I
am still quite active and and I've
certainly been streaming and working on
Sparkie and all that stuff so hopefully
I'll have time to make some kind of
update video or whatnot while I'm over
there because I was gonna make like a
dev vlog or a summary video about
Sparky's new features and all of that
and I do still want to get around to
doing that and maybe if I don't like if
my laptop microphone is rubbish or
something it should be okay it's like a
MacBook Pros but where it shouldn't be
too bad but um I'll see if I can make
like a vlog or something over there cuz
I think I did that last year so anyway
that's what's gonna happen so make sure
you subscribe to that Channel archive
channel if you want to catch all the
latest and greatest from Sparky and also
it's been a great time making videos for
you guys
40,000 subscribers again thank you very
much for that and I will see you
probably soon good bye
warm